vessel HMS mercy heading to the Straits
of Dover an escalation of Britain's
response to the migration problem
numbers of migrants willing to take the
perilous journey across the English
Channel has increased dramatically over
the Christmas period prompting questions
about why people are desperate enough to
take the risk
so Sky News spent the day with a group
of migrants many who have risked their
lives to get here they all arrived in
the UK as unaccompanied children and a
local Kent refugee charity has arranged
this trip for them to see London
Daniel fled Eritrea aged 14 his journey
here cost him five thousand dollars I
had not planned to come over UK to come
here well my plan was just to left to
come to the left my country and then say
there life when I come to Italy Italy
they didn't do anything for me I was in
the street for a couple of weeks friends
the same
yeah I've been living the same Sudan the
same did you try to claim asylum in
France or Italy
I mean how easy was it to claim asylum
here the UK is the fifth most popular
destination for asylum claims in Europe
France had three times more in 2017
Germany over double that but some people
make it their mission to get to Dover
like Kemal who got on a lorry in Calais
after a year of trying people want to
come here for a reason you know
spray spray yeah it's argued the UK is a
comparatively soft touch and that is the
attraction some people say well I'm like
France we should make it more hostile
and then people wouldn't come here sure
but you're I mean you're talking to
young people who've come to the UK I
mean the figures just don't bear out
that everybody wants to come here and
most most people claiming asylum don't
come to
okay so what I would say to people
saying you know they're all heading here
is that's just not true
Salim's family members were killed in
Sudan but his journey across the
Mediterranean was just as treacherous
the body is so narrow right and it's a
lot of people about 120 people in the
body right it's difficult on a team game
sometimes people die in a body
did you see people die I have my friend
they gonna where they die
these are people that they then I have
us too for us to go to Italy so there's
people even sometimes they come and take
the people outside the waters and they
ask them to give their money right and
he didn't give them any money so yes
they didn't give money so that is why
they kill them their traumatic
beginnings could end well the young
people we met all have ambitious plans
for lives they hope to continue living
here in the UK
Jason Farrell Sky News